hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie rage live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster well it's just his
second week in the job and Rishi zunek
remains under pressure on immigration
the number of people crossing the
channel and the conditions they face
when they get here the immigration
Minister has told this program the home
office now faces a judicial review over
it plus the PM will now go to the cop
climate change conference a decision
that I'm sure has absolutely nothing to
do with the fact that Boris Johnson says
he's going as well so there's plenty for
us to get stuck into as we bring you
takes from all sides over the next 60
minutes
it's coming don't worry
here we are border control is a serious
complex issue
it is a party opposite not have a plan
they have opposed every single measure
we
you can't attack a plan if you don't
have a plan
or would she see neck face some pretty
stingy attacks in PM Keys today over the
Asylum and migration system
why doesn't he get a proper Home
Secretary scrap the Rwanda gimmick crack
down on smuggling gangs in the Small
Boat Crossings speed up Asylum claims
and agree an international deal on rifty
start governing for once and get a Dream
well we have plenty of that and more but
there were of course some early signs of
progress in the polls for the new PM is
the brief honeymoon period over now or
does it continue we'll try and find out
by asking our viewers panel what they
made of all of that and of course the
thorny issue too of Channel Crossings
they're most of them are missing one
person I'm sure everyone will be here
when we come to get your views in a few
moments we'll also have some top guests
for you including the immigration
Minister Robert generick the shadow
policing Minister Labor's Sarah Jones
will be here too and the snp's
Westminster business and energy
spokesperson Stephen Flynn will be on
the show plus we'll be talking to the
conservative MP Vicki Ford much more
besides coming up on the take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good evening well it was a pretty
bruising second pmqs for Rishi Scenic
today Labor's care Starman went on the
attack over Channel Crossings and Asylum
claims it's a story that really isn't
going away we'll soon find out of course
how the government will plug the black
hole in the public finances as we learn
that all of Russia sunax leadership
campaign pledges are now under review so
let's crack straight on shall we we're
going to start with the best bits of the
week so far
the Home Secretary is under growing
pressure this morning over the treatment
of refugees and migrants when they
arrive in the UK there are now 4 000
people in a facility that was designed
to hold 1 500 and it's led to what I
would regard as a breach of Humane
conditions the British people deserve to
know which party is
I would never demonize people coming to
this country invasion is a way of
describing the sheer scale of the
challenge former Health secretary Matt
cork has reportedly signed up to join
I'm a celebrity get me out of here we've
heard from the chief whip of the
conservative party and he has already
had the whip suspended it's not
acceptable for conservative members of
parliament to go on Celebrity television
programs when parliament's sitting but
are you going to go to cop 27
yes as it happens we start with breaking
news and the prime minister is going to
cop 27. so why doesn't he get a proper
Home Secretary scrap the Rwanda gimmick
crack down on smuggling gangs in the
Small Boat Crossings speed up Asylum
claims and agree an international deal
on rifty start governing for once and
get a group this is the person who in
2019 told the BBC and I quote I do think
Jeremy corbyn would make a great prime
minister
[Applause]
well they were the most compelling
should we say bits of the week uh so far
Matt Hancock had to get into that
Montage didn't he but of course it's the
situation in the channel and the
conditions for those that reach this
side that really continues to dominate
today the chairs are for House of
Commons select committees have now
written to the Home Secretary expressing
their concerns about the manston Asylum
processing center a little earlier I
spoke to the immigration Minister Robert
shamrick
is it true that the home office is now
subject to a judicial review over the
treatment of people at the manston
Immigration Center
uh well good evening I believe we have
received uh the initial contact for a
judicial review That's Not Unusual this
is a highly litigious area of policy but
of course as the minister responsible I
want to ensure that everything that we
do is conducted appropriately and within
the law and so in the week that I've
been in post I have tried to work night
and day to ensure that the manston site
is not just legally compliant but is a
Humane and compassionate place where we
welcome those migrants treat them
appropriately and then they leave
quickly to Alternative accommodation and
I'm very pleased to say this evening
that that's exactly the path that we're
on the number of people at manston has
fallen very substantially since the
weekend when we became aware of the
specific issues and got involved so
directly and I think we're on a path now
whereby within a matter of days assuming
we don't see very large numbers of
further migrants arriving a across the
channel I don't think that's going to
happen because we have good forecasts of
the weather and the other intelligence
that we have from northern France so I
expect that manston will be returned to
a well-functioning and certainly legally
compliant site very rapidly a matter of
days what's changed have you basically
tried to take over Robin's brief on this
nope absolutely not we've been working
extremely closely together and we've
procured more hotels we have extra
support we've got brilliant officers
from border Force supported by
contractors and members of the Armed
Forces and we're processing the migrants
who are in the camp very quickly just on
the judicial review do you know if it's
been brought by I don't think I can
comment on on what might be ongoing
legal action they're not the only people
who are concerned uh this evening four
parliamentary committee chairs including
two conservatives have also written to
ask what the home office is doing to
address the conditions in munston they
worried in particular about the
conditions children are being held in
and the use of thoughts and physical
searches
you know being honest are you worried as
well well when I visited the camp on uh
Sunday I thought conditions were poor
and they needed to change rapidly that's
exactly well mainly because of the
number of people who are there remember
this facility was functioning acceptably
just a matter of weeks ago what's
changed is that we've had a very large
number of individuals across the channel
in small boats we would love to think we
can control that but of course that's
not entirely within our control and then
we had this terrible attack on Sunday by
this individual endova which caused us
to evacuate the almost 1 000 people who
are there and bring them immediately to
the site and that increased the numbers
from 3000 which was already too many to
four thousand where there was real
strain on the site I would just say
having been there that some of the
reporting is inaccurate there were
suggestions that there have been
diseases like diphtheria running wild in
the the facility that's not correct to
the best of my knowledge there have been
four cases out of thousands of
individuals each of those cases We
Believe came into the site if you like
rather than being caught there there's a
very good medical facility when I was
there on Sunday there were two emergency
doctors there were paramedics and nurses
everybody is clothed they're fed they're
supported whilst they're there just as
you'd expect we you know we have values
the country just because somebody's
chosen to come as a migrant we don't
want them to come in this way in small
boats but when they're here we'll treat
them appropriately and that's exactly
what we are doing and what we want to
get to uh in the coming days and it's
not just an issue that is about this one
Immigration Center though is it it's
about the strain on the system as a
whole and I just want to look now at a
chart showing the UK Asylum caseload it
effectively shows a rising number of
cases a class is still in process
without a full resolution
I mean is that really good enough no no
it's clearly not good enough and we have
a task to do now as I said I'm new in
the position suela Bravo and the Home
Secretary has only been in position for
six or seven weeks as well so together
we're going to work intensively to
reduce that backlog of cases we've
already put a significant amount of
extra resource behind this we have a
thousand people working on cases the
system is quite slow in this country
compared to some of our comparators like
France and Germany we think we can
improve productivity get people
processing the claims much faster but I
would just say that all of what we've
been talking about in the last week are
the symptoms of the problem the problem
is the fact that 40 000 people have
chosen to get into small boats to cross
the channel at the behest of dangerous
illegal criminal gangs and we are having
to try to cope with that and our
infrastructure was never designed for 40
000 people to come in small boats and to
land on our beaches will be saved at Sea
by border force rnli and the Royal Navy
with the best wool in the world they
would always put immense strain on our
system just to come back because you
said that they've chosen to come
if you're not from Hong Kong or Ukraine
or Afghanistan where there are specific
and bespoke legal ways to claim Asylum
or to claim an immigration claim to come
to the UK
how do you reclaim Asylum legally in the
UK because you only have to make the
claim when you're in the UK and you're
supposed to claim in the first safe
country you land in so it's impossible
isn't it no it's not great when the
first firstly the numbers on the schemes
you just quoted are very large so
there's a hundred and fifty thousand
people in this country from Ukraine my
point is this is part of the reason why
well if you're from another country and
you feel that you are unsafe and you
want to claim yourself you finish that
point firstly the numbers are very large
from those places so the suggestion made
by some that the UK is not a big-hearted
generous country that's trying to play
its part in a global migration crisis is
not correct because we've issued 130 000
Hong Kong bno visas we've got 150 000
people here under the homes for Ukraine
scheme we bought tens of thousands of
Afghans to the UK in addition to that
there are other safe and legal routes
there's a community sponsorship route
which would enable churches synagogues
more
Community groups to sponsor individuals
to come here we have another scheme
where we work with the unhcr to enable
people who are in real distress often in
Refugee campuses to say that the advice
on the website said you should apply
when you you should apply for Asylum
when you arrive in the UK and also says
your claim might not be considered if
you travel to the UK through a safe
that's right isn't it well I just I mean
I I think fundamentally that's the right
approach if you're in a safe country
like France that's where you should
claim Asylum I think the British public
are absolutely flabbergasted that there
are people in France who don't deem that
to be a safe country and put themselves
on there often their children as well in
immense danger to come to the UK you
know we want a system where we can
support people who are genuinely in
danger who are escaping War persecution
serious human rights abuses like we're
doing with Hong Kong Afghanistan and
Ukraine we do not want a system that
takes people literally out of the sea
often who are economic migrants and
prioritizes those over people well a
very substantial uh minority perhaps
more are economic migrants I mean if you
look at the example of Albania this year
a quarter of those people who've come in
small boats have come from Albania
Albania is a demonstrably safe country
it's a European country you've got Eddie
Rahman the prime minister of Albania
tonight saying you know don't talk
Albania down we're a safe country it is
not right
targeting Albanian albanians as the
cause of Britain's common border
problems makes the easy rhetoric but
ignores hard fact well I want to have a
constructive and productive relationship
with our Albanian friends that's
extremely under strange that's extremely
important but it is correct that a
quarter of people who've come in small
boats have come from Albany this year
and the ncar National Crime organization
has said that a very significant
proportion of serious organized crime is
emanating from those individuals and
again I think there are millions of
people who've been watching your program
this evening who would think why on
Earth is this country spending thousands
of pounds on hotels on support for young
men coming from a safe country either we
shouldn't do that at all or we should
prioritize that on people in genuine
danger such as an Afghan interpreter and
their family who served the United
Kingdom with honor and distinction and
those are the people we should be
working to support now we are running
out of time you're already um you know
close Ally of the Prime Minister you're
described in some articles as his
closest friend in Parliament it feels
like you're doing a lot of heavy lifting
if I may say on the media rounds such as
this evening on one of the biggest
challenging challenges facing government
are you the de facto Home Secretary no
no obviously not and although though I
am good friends with Rishi sunai my
longest friendship in politics is Sue
Ella Brotherman who I've known for 20
years and I have huge respect for her
she is a great Home Secretary and one of
the things that she is good at is
articulating the genuine concerns of the
British public on this issue so you
haven't been put in position as
immigration Minister I guess in case the
ball did come she and us she and I are
working in lockstep on this issue
because the British public expect their
government to provide safe borders and a
fair and robust immigration system and
that's exactly what we intend to deliver
oh we're out of time thank you thank you
Robert John Rick there confirming there
is a judicial review going on into the
treatment of people at the manston
Immigration Center are also saying that
they're on a path to a well-functioning
and legally compliant site within days
well let's get Labor's take now on the
situation uh shall we can talk to the
shadow policing Minister Sarah Jones
who's with us this evening thank you so
much for being with us
um well we just heard from Robert genre
there um what was your reaction to what
he was saying I had you listening well
he said the British public expect a
proper system that is safe and fair that
is not what we have and today is
Groundhog Day because 18 months ago
pretty Patel stood up and said the
Asylum system's broken I've got a plan
I'm going to fix it it's got worse since
then and we now have a situation as we
talked about in prime minister's
question time today where only four
percent of the people who came across on
small boats last year have been
processed this is a problem of the
government's making because the delays
and are now so long the decision making
is so collapsed and the number of
returns is so low we're returning a
tenth of what we used to do that the
whole system is is an opportunity for
those criminal gangs to really exploit
people and to get them to this country
because what's going to happen they're
not going to be they're not going to
have their Asylum claim looked at for at
least a year and possibly not returned
even if they're turned down the whole
system is chaotic and that's where
criminal gangs are making the most of it
and exploiting people and people are
making those difficult dangerous
Journeys I take your point of course
about how long the conservatives have
been in power but this is a new
Administration under Russia sunac he's
got a new immigration Minister as well
who acknowledged that the processing
times are not good enough but they are
putting more resources into trying to
correct that Robert gemrick also saying
that things are improving at manston and
they're on a path to a well-functioning
and legally compliant site within days I
mean I guess you can judge them in a few
days but if things do improve should you
give them any credit
would know the system has been broken
for a long time we've known this the
home Affairs select committee had a
really damning report back in July
saying look this is a huge problem the
number of people coming in is only going
to increase this is not some surprise
shift uh in what's happening we've seen
it coming and of course in Madison it's
been absolutely devastating and the
local MP has said
it was working fine in manston until
five or six weeks ago when the Home
Secretary he says took a policy decision
not to increase the number of hotels and
and therefore we've seen the big
increase of people and and children
sleeping on cardboard which is awful and
reports today that people have been
taken to Victoria Station and left there
not even given accommodation I mean the
whole thing is chaotic and it all comes
down to how the government seems
incapable of running anything uh
including the Asylum system do you know
anything more about this judicial review
who are you learning as we are I'm
learning as you are but I I'm not
surprised and we've said this is gonna
cost the taxpayer money because you
can't break the law and put people in
those conditions and just ignore that
and allow that to happen of course there
are going to be implications of of
judicial reviews that that are going to
cost money the government should have
got a grip of this months ago actually
years ago and there are they are failing
to tackle the criminal gangs who are
driving this process they are failing to
do the administration yes because you
know I've heard you talk about uh
criminal gangs I asked you about Cooper
about Labor's plan to stop the small
boat she said it was all about criminal
gangs kirst armor again mentioning it at
pmqs it's very easy to say let's stop
criminal gangs everyone would agree with
that statement but it's very hard to do
it isn't it that's just classic
opposition politics I would say not all
uh let's look at where you put your
priorities so the government want to or
they have already spent 140 million
pounds on a Rwanda scheme that they
announced that hasn't happened and we
think will probably never happen
and doesn't work anyway uh instead of
spending the money on the Rwanda scheme
we would spend the money on the National
Crime agency having a new uh Workforce
there of people who can crack down on
those gangs now it's not easy I'm not
promising that it is but if you put the
resources there you make choices in
government about where you put your
money and where you put your priorities
we have to work with other countries
because we know that the criminal
networks are not just in the UK they're
across multiple countries so we have to
work with our allies on tackling it but
that's where we need the expertise the
National Crime agency is really good and
we know it's also at risk of being cut
under the new uh regime from Rishi sunak
so we we need to know that the
government is going to keep the resource
there but we would put more resourcing
is important but it is still very very
difficult you know I was really into
Interpol it says about these people
smuggling gangs low risk of detraction
and prosecution and arrest compared to
other activities of transnational organs
as crime they go on to say the
relationship between criminals and
migrants is very much a temporary one
making the criminals difficult to trace
they're generally unknown to the people
who are smuggling they hide behind
pseudonyms in encrypted chats use Rental
Vehicles different mobile phone numbers
you can put more money in that doesn't
mean that it's going to be easy to do
something but you can disrupt their
model and disrupting their model means
getting rid of a system that means that
if you get to the UK you'll be a year
before your assist your case is
processed and you might not be returned
even if you're turned down as an asylum
Seeker the criminal gangs can say
there's no other legal route this is
your only option you'll be in the UK for
at least a year it's worth spending your
money we need to disrupt that as well as
going after the criminal gangs okay
thank you very much really interesting
to talk and Sarah Jones out from labor
and a little later we will hear from the
s p as well but first let's just try and
work out what we've learned from the two
first interviews uh shall we joined as
usual with our Deputy political editor
at Sam coats thanks for being with us
Sam
um so what what did you make of the
interviews where where are we this
evening
so let's talk about the bigger picture
in relation to tonight's developing an
unfolding story which is manston the
fact the government pacing uh a legal
action confirmed to you by the
immigration Minister Robert generic in
just a moment but I just want to start
on what I thought was an extraordinary
line from Robert generick in your
interview
now he confirmed that the government is
now going to have to justify in court
why what it was doing was legal and on
your program he said I expect Manson
will be returned to a well-functioning
and legally compliant site very rapidly
well that sounds awfully like a minister
sitting in your chair admitting that
what's going on here in manston near uh
rounds getting Kent isn't legal as the
government's about to have to face a
fight over exactly that point in court
so I'm not sure quite whether that will
then play into the kind of legal
arguments that we're gonna see but it
it's quite clear right right now there
are protesters outside uh uh this uh
Center
um the numbers are we understand going
down of Asylum Seekers and Robert Janet
talked about that in your interview I
mean that he talked about because of
good forecast let's turn that around
it's because bad weather forecast
because what happened at the weekend
that put such pressure was the lovely
weather that many people were enjoying
actually that enabled lots of people to
come over in small boats and that put
this extraordinary pressure uh Laird
upon the kind of chronic systemic
problems people are sleeping on Floors
sleeping in chairs and he denied that
the scabies was a consequence of what
was going on in there but clearly a big
problem with lots to fix the Chief
Inspector of borders and immigration
saying he was speechless at the
conditions in there now this is all like
plugging into a difficult political area
for the government but right now given
suela breatherman was given legal advice
that several sources told the Sunday
Times and others that she ignored about
the conditions inside here for a
minister tonight to be basically
admitting what was going on was illegal
just feels like quite a problem yeah the
judicial review it really feels like
that is a story that is going to run and
run
just thinking about it Sam as well
um how much do you think this debate
matters to people right now
well I think that the issue of migration
and borders is quite important to people
uh according to the Polly it's not as as
important as it as it perhaps once was
it was before uh the brexit um
referendum and and what's interesting
talking to MPS today uh in Parliament is
that they're not overly worried about
the tough stance of this woman the Home
Secretary Zoella Braverman they're not
they're not worried that she's going to
lose her job but they are worried that
they just don't know how the richest in
that government is going to cope with
difficult moments and the huge amounts
of pressure and we'll talk about that
later in the program when you're back I
love this photo by the way that's well
then Robert generic just standing there
behind him uh let's talk now to the S
P's Westminster spokesperson on business
and energy at Stephen Flynn thank you
very much for being with us good to have
you a first time I think on the program
um just first of all your reaction we
heard Robert genre there uh confirming
there will be a judicial review into
what's happening at this Immigration
Center I I think that's probably the
long overdue there's been concerns
raised about the conditions there for
some considerable time I know this is
not a new issue and we've had a wide
range in discussion in and around
migration into these shows for for a
long period of time now this is clear
the UK government don't have control
they've admitted that themselves but I
have real concerns about the rhetorics
that's getting used in you mentioned
several problem and the rhetorical is
appalling from from my perspective if we
look at it in real terms the UK is
around about 16th in the league tables
of Europe of European nations for as
people trying to claim Asylum we're
nowhere near being swarmed or invaded as
she's putting putting forward and when
we're talking about these things we need
to remember that we're talking about
people primarily people who are fleeing
the likes of Afghanistan Syria war-tone
countries there is no safe legal way to
get here the government got rid of them
if they want to to create solutions they
need to sort out the home office and
they need to recreate those safe legal
groups
um I guess just to put the other
perspective from the government they
would say that there is an increasing
number of people who are using the small
boats to cross the channel which is
dangerous and that although many of
those people are successful in claiming
Asylum they would say that there's also
been a spike in economic migrants from
places like Albania due to think there's
any justification in that argument well
in excess of 75 of people as I
understand that are who are putting in
for Asylum claims are being granted them
which indicates that they are here
legally and if there was a safe legal
route for them to get here that didn't
involve getting in a dinghy okay
oh yeah well of course there may be
people who have escaping who are
escaping the net but that would be
complete speculation but of those people
who are coming here who we do know about
all those things they are claiming
Asylum they're being granted Asylum by
the UK government which means they have
a legitimate right to be here we need to
respect that we need to look after these
people we need to stop treating them
like animals and start treating them
like people uh now I want to talk to you
a little bit about Richardson because it
feels like he has taken a different
attitude should we say towards the s p
and Nicholson as well compared to Liz
trust
um he's said that he wants to work with
her uh called her and the first day in
office unlike at his Prudence I said do
you have any more optimism I mean if
he's doing more than those trusts it's a
very low bar she stared quite publicly
she wanted to ignore Scotland's
democratically elected uh first Minister
and I appears that she did that I have
grave concerns about Russia sunax
Premiership not least the fact that he
wants to go down routes particularly in
relation to brexit in relation to
immigration which might pardon people of
Scotland of course don't support but the
biggest issue here is the fact the
people of Scotland have given the
Scottish government a democratic mandate
for our second Independence referendum
every sunak wants to be treated as well
then he'll respect that I have a feeling
he won't know do you would you have any
evidence for that or is it just what you
you were expecting from him well the
tourists have been very clear
consecutive Prime Ministers I think
we're on our fifth most since the the
last Independence referendum have been
clear that they're not going to grant
that section starting order to allow the
people of Scotland to to choose their
Futures but we need to bear in mind
there's been three general elections
there's been two Scottish parliamentary
elections there's been three Scottish
local elections and indeed a European
Parliament election since 2014 this SMP
have won every single one people aren't
just virtual independent so are they I
accept of course you know the the clues
of the name uh you you guys want a
referendum on Independence uh however
people vote for all sorts of different
reasons don't they yeah but I think
let's let's be realistic here the people
of Scotland are very well informed
they'll actually know what the SMP stand
for they know what we represent we have
represented Scotch Independence for a
long time and of course the green party
in Scotland has been making great
strides as well but also a
pro-independence party and along with
them in the Scottish Parliament we have
a majority in favor of a Scottish
independence referendum we're all
eagerly awaiting the outcome of the
Supreme Court but from our perspective
the Democratic mandate is clear and
hopefully originally could come to his
senses okay thank you very much for
being on the program good to talk to you
this evening you are watching uh the
take we're live in Westminster for you
this evening up next we're going to take
a closer look at promises questions and
hear our question of the week
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back time now for one of
my favorite parts of the show where we
take a closer look at Prime Minister's
questions here's what a political
correspondent Ali Fortescue made of it
all in pmq's unwrapped
it was released second outing at the
dispatch box and this time labor had
more ammunition after a week that's been
focused on chaos in the immigration
system every one of kirst Armor's six
questions on the government's record on
tackling migration his Home Secretary
says the Asylum system is broken
who broke it the number of people
deported to Rwanda is zero since then 30
000 people have crossed the channel in
small bloat it's not working so why
doesn't he get a proper Home Secretary
scrap the Rwanda gimmick Crackdown on
smuggling gangs in the Small Boat
Crossings speed up Asylum claims and
agree an international deal start
governing for once and get a group
even some Tories have privately conceded
secure's tactics were effective he even
forced this admission from Rishi sunak
of all the people who arrived in small
boats last year how many Asylum claims
have been processed not enough is the
answer very straightforwardly not enough
and that's what we're going to fix and
so Rishi sinak reached for old attack
lines falling back once again on
secure's predecessor this is the person
who in 2019 told the BBC and I quote I
do think Jeremy corbyn would make a
great prime minister
he may want to forget about it but we
will remind him of it every week because
as the conservative government that will
keep this country safe
[Music]
a spokesperson for labor said after that
corbyn barbs make the pm look desperate
and the public know the party's changed
as for the embattled Home Secretary last
week under attack she barely flinched
this week's swella Braven was animated
visibly defending herself her expression
said it all
and the tough questions came too from
the blue benches including this from a
keen Boris backer prime minister during
the summer you set out a comprehensive
10-point plan to tackle this issue
everybody on this side of a chamber
wants you to succeed in this aim when
can we expect the firm action the
British people
and pmqs couldn't pass without reference
to Matt Hancock's Venture into reality
TV could he also recognize the value
that our trade deals are doing in
allowing us to export our high quality
produce around the world in particular
the Australia agreement where a member
of this house will be able to enjoy a
certain delicate cut in his Bush tracker
top tiles
it drew a laugh from the PM but no
comment on Mr Hancock's decision as a
man helping Mr sunac prep for pmqs
watched on it was an assured performance
from the new prime minister but attacks
on the conservative record on
immigration are hard to defend for a
party who've been in power for 12 years
week two and Rishi sunak's problems are
piling up
at Ally foresky they're talking us
through the commons this afternoon so
what are people watching on Sky News
make of it all we can bring in uh
viewers panel at this minute a regular
panel of viewers hello everyone good to
see you all
um I'm really interested I think uh
today to talk to you about immigration
we've been talking about an awful lot on
the program it dominated at pmqs and
really just to get a bit of a sense from
you about what what people actually
think are on it and we can talk to
Hannah first Hannah Underwood and I'm
interested to get your perspective
Hannah because I know that you used to
work in law enforcement and dealt with
quite a lot of organized illegal
immigration so what's your take and
what's a really difficult subject
wow where do we start
um
I think these problems have been going
on for years and it's a really difficult
uh problem there the solutions are not
very easy
um but certainly I think Labor's got the
right sort of ideas I think working with
uh the French working with other
countries Upstream trying to tackle the
problem there
getting rid of the gangs getting rid of
the leaders of the gangs Prosecuting
them disrupting them seizing the boats
that sort of thing I think really is
most effective rather than waiting until
they come here
um but certainly when they are here we
cannot treat them in the way that we've
seen the Austin place
um you know they have to be treated
properly and with respect
um
it's it's a very big problem and
nobody's got some sort of magic Panacea
for it but I think we just have to as I
say work with our European Partners yeah
and the folks on the gangs but also as
you say perhaps acknowledging there's no
magic wand that anyone can can wave
let's talk to Vic now shall we Vic
Daniels a conservative voter
um what's your take on how the
conservatives are approaching this
um well I think it is a very difficult
issue
um I struggled to understand
um however how people can come from
France and claim that they're in a
unsafe environment
um uh it's you know it's it's maybe a
politically incorrect view but I'm kind
of being a Daily Mail reader
um you know 99 of Daily Mail readers in
a poll that was published today
um confirmed that that they were in
agreement with a much more stricter
policy
um as well Brotherman is uh uh is
suggesting um it is a difficult issue at
the end of the day Britannia no longer
rules the waves clearly and it's no
surprise that there are issues because
we can't cope we're in we're facing
difficult Financial uh decisions and
choices and we're not in a position to
to cope with the number of people that
are crossing the channel it's no
surprise yeah thank you very much for
sharing your take on the situation and
what the best attitude is to have on the
sort of number of small boats let's
bring in Nikki Todd shall we next you
describe yourself as a Centrist when it
comes to politics what's your take shall
we say on the number of people crossing
the channel
I don't think it's a question of how
many people are actually crossing the
channel I think it's a question of what
we do with them how we behave what what
we show the world at the moment the
government is more interested in Dogma
in actually persuading their party that
they are doing really well in the hope
that when the revolving doll spins again
they will get a better job or the top
job
um not really interested in how to
present UK PLC to the world out there it
should be about
um compassion about doing the right
thing about processes in the home office
that actually work for what they are all
this change that keeps happening in the
government it means that no processes
are in place nobody is actually checking
to make sure they're happening so
everybody arrives and says it wasn't me
it was my predecessor
and then
they're gone before they can do anything
about it this kind of thing provides
very poor
um workmanship and ability
um to pass that as normal so perhaps an
acknowledgment that more needs to be
done with the processes in the home
office to improve the situation right
let's bring in sweet DACA at shall we
who's talking to us from Leicester this
evening now I know you expect my
producer Jared a little earlier saying
that you came as a skilled migrant to
the UK obviously very very different
situation and but do you think we need
to change our attitude I guess towards
people coming to the country
yeah good evening Sophie thank you for
having me
um yeah I mean it's an incredibly
difficult one I mean uh as a skilled
migrant I have to jump through various
Hoops before I ultimately got the rights
to save the thousands of pounds and fees
and and whatnot
um and my stance is actually yes there
is a case for being uh stricter with the
illegal immigration but we also need to
be fair and Humane
um I also quite agree with your previous
uh panel in terms of uh we need to get
rid of policies that are just there to
keep the extreme right-wing on site you
know the Rand work policy for example
140 million pounds could be better spent
in actually processing the applications
of these applicants who come from uh
quite dire difficult situations
uh so there's that and then the other is
obviously I think someone else mentioned
uh it's an incredibly difficult and a
global problem and we can't go at it
alone uh so we need to uh work
collaboratively with our partners in
Europe
and other countries in order to you know
solve this hobby really interesting and
to hear your thoughts thank you very
much let's bring in Chloe shall we Chloe
conserved a photo talking to us from uh
Cumbria what's your take on the
immigration uh scene
um I very much agree with what Rick was
just sorry Vic was just saying and we've
got a massive massive problem and I
think it's going to take a lot to sort
of come out of it I think
um avishi is brilliant in so many ways
however I just think they're completely
out of the depth with all this okay and
so we're getting a bit of a split I
guess on some of the views of the panel
which I guess does you know show the
difference of opinion in the country
let's bring in Rob Kennedy apologies Rob
I think we are actually struggling to
get to speak to you while we've got a
technical issue and we will definitely
try and get you another time so big
apologies right before you guys go I
need to ask you this question
it's about Matt Hancock the story of the
week for many people put your hand up if
you think he's right to go into the
jungle
when I'm a celebrity hands up if you
back him Vic you're the only person but
I want you to put your hand up now if
you're going to watch him on the jungle
put your hand up go on
go on there must be okay two out of six
more highbrow than me I have to say
thank you very much for giving us your
takes on the show this evening great to
talk to you all and apologies again for
the issues there Rob now it's our
regular chance to speak to about Venture
as we pick our pmq of the week the one
that really caught our eye during the
session earlier and today it's this one
in last Summer's Heat Wave people across
Essex witnessed terrible fires and last
month in Ethiopia I witnessed the
horrific climate change driven drought
that is forcing millions of people
across the Horn of Africa to the brink
of famine I've discussed climate change
with my right honorable friend I know he
cares and it's great that he's going to
show my shake but we the UK brought the
world to Glasgow for cop 26 it's vital
that we remain world leaders on climate
change so please confirm this government
will fulfill the promises that we the UK
made in Glasgow yes well can I thank my
honorable friend for her work and role
that she has played in us championing
the fight against climate change and I
agree with her there is no long-term
Prosperity without action on climate
change and there is no energy security
without investment in Renewables that's
why I will attend cop 27 next week to
deliver to deliver Mr Speaker on
glasgow's Legacy of building a secure
clean and sustainable future
[Music]
well that question was from the concerto
MP Vicki Ford who is former minister in
the foreign office and she joins us now
thank you very much for being with us
um what did you make of Russia's unex
response to your question
well first of all I was so pleased that
we'd heard just before pmqs that he will
be going to Sean will shake for the next
cop meeting
um I think that's really important and
and um I know we've got lots of issues
domestically but I'm really glad he went
there and I was glad that he confirmed
very clearly that in his View we can't
have that long-term Prosperity that he
is so focused on if we don't also focus
on climate change and that is the big
picture is that's so important for our
long-term future so I was very pleased
that he was so clear with that
commitment
do you have concerns about how seriously
this Administration does take climate
change you know coming off the back of
Boris Johnson he made it such a key part
of his uh Premiership uh which is sunak
has said that you know he's going to
u-turn on the policy from this trust to
have more onshore wind farms in a time
of austerity potentially with spending
carts fiscal constraints do you think it
might slip down the agenda under Rishi
scenic
well I think it's really important that
it doesn't slip down the agenda and I
had a chance to speak to the Prime
Minister again immediately after pmqs
and he was very clear that he doesn't
want to slip down the agenda we've
obviously got a lot of domestic
challenges on our economy but so do
other countries across the world
um and so I'm very glad he is going to
cop that's a sign that it won't be
slipping down the agenda and we need to
keep focused on that we you know we need
energy security to have energy security
we need the focus on Renewables I think
many of us who are interested in climate
issues were also very pleased that he
had
um taken fracking off the table and made
it very clear that we shouldn't be doing
that we need to focus on the cleaner
Greener Renewables as well you say that
you're very glad that he is going to go
to the cop climate change Summit that
shows that he's taking it seriously
some would say that what it really shows
is that he doesn't want to be upstaged
by Boris Johnson do you think the time
here that's a bit strange you know he
only said he was going after Boris
Johnson said he was
I think you know everybody wants prime
minister to be in 50 million different
places at once and they can't be
everywhere and obviously he's taken over
a very very recently only last week at a
time when we need a lot of focus on our
own economy and we're waiting of course
for the economic statement so it is
absolutely right that he's spent time uh
this week really focusing on that and
I'm glad that she's therefore now in a
position to be going off to meet other
world leaders and and that's where he
will be he will be meeting the other
world leaders who are there in Egypt
next week I do want to if I may ask you
a question about the story that we are
leading on today which is the
immigration uh scenes that we're seeing
at the number of small boats crossing
the channels and of course the home the
I was going to say homes actually there
but the immigration Minister I should
say Robert generic uh confirming to me
today that there will be a judicial
review into conditions at manston
How concerned are you about what is
happening
well I think you know it is really
concerning and it's really difficult and
it's a huge number of people which is
putting huge pressure on all sorts of
different local services but I also
think it's another reason why we need to
look at the long-term causes of why
people are leaving different countries I
mean when I was in the Horn of Africa
two weeks ago you know what I saw was
just devastating I mean we've heard
about droughts in Ethiopia in the past
of course but nothing like what's
happening now it's the worst in at least
the past 40 years and where you have
these climate impacts sometimes with
conflict impacts you then do get
instability that causes migration that
impacts on us back at home and that's
why it's also so important that we
remember that for our own security and
stability at home we need to be
investing in support and development of
other countries too I've very
interesting perspective Vicki thought
that thank you for being on the program
and talking us through your PM key
thank you you're watching the take we're
live in Westminster for you this evening
up next we'll round up everything we've
heard and also do a bit of post-match
analysis as well
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you 9pm 9pm is the time for debate
time for discussions
time for answers the evidence is there
time to join the conversation to try and
make sense of issues that affect you 9pm
9pm 9pm is the soundtrack to your
weeknights on Sky News I'm inza man
Rasheed and I'm Skies north of England
correspondent telling stories from this
culturally Rich region I call home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
thank you
the Taliban found your family what would
happen I think they're just going to
straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in all levels of
cricket I was in the balcony a couple of
times I was nearly gone
football is a joy to watch and when
people are disappointed you can feel the
hate
[Music]
I just felt physically safe sales I was
like that that's really in my system
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
even before the pandemic GPS were
pleading for help government expects
more face-to-face contact with patients
in return
men they want to force you doing
something which you don't want to do
just because you're homeless and you're
looking for a warm place to sleep
we give a voice to communities often
unheard and unserved from a region with
a distinct history and Global impact
[Music]
good
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take we've had lots of
takes this evening so time for a bit of
post-match analysis a bit of a round up
with our Deputy political editor Sam
coats who is here again thank you so
much for being with us you've been
crunching through some poll numbers for
us tonight haven't you what have you
been looking at that's right Sophie now
polls at this point always a bit of a
snapshot not a prediction and we've only
had barely over a week of British soon
act but already there's some movement so
let's have a little look now this is how
people say they're going to vote blue
obviously conservatives red Labor uh
yellow is the liberal Democrats and what
you can see here is the conservatives on
23 labor well ahead on 51 but what
you're seeing you can see that just with
those little lines there just a smallest
start of a little bit of a contraction
in that Gap but obviously an enormous
Gap that would still mean a landslide
for labor at the moment it's always very
much hoping they can do a bit more with
that over time but if we look at the
next one you can see what Rishi sunac
has achieved now this is what they think
of their leaders so the blue line here
mostly is Boris Johnson until it gets to
Liz truss most recently uh the vertical
drop there is absolutely horrendous and
then this red line here is Kirsten so
you can see that kirstama who's on 34
well ahead of Liz trust when she left on
13. but Rishi sunak on 30s just a four
point gap just really really close so
actually I think the conclusion is on
first glance people quite like but she's
seen that almost as much as kirstama and
does because this is the person rather
than the party isn't it I think it does
I mean I think when you saw what you saw
with David Cameron back 2006 7 8 9 10
and then in the leader of 2015 election
that he pulled ahead of his party and
that ultimately dragged the Tory ratings
up but it doesn't automatically mean
that the conservatives will eat anything
anything like recover in the next
election so let's look at the mountain
to climb that's the next slide
and here it is uh this is the government
so this is the percentage of people who
think the government doing well that's
the greenish line uh and doing badly
that's the reddish like you can see an
enormous Gap again at just the smallest
sign of recovery but I think the Damage
Done by Liz trust to the Tory party and
the Damage Done by the latter period of
Boris Johnson to the Tory party is going
to take a heck of a loss of undoing now
if you go back to 2018 29 the end of uh
the end of the Theresa May years and the
beginning of the Boris Johnson news you
can close that Gap and win an election
we saw that in 2019 so so just because
there's a big gap doesn't mean it's all
lost but there's an enormous way to go
really interesting
um Rishi sunak himself what do you take
I guess it was I thought it was really
interesting to see as you say how he
does seem to be polling ahead of the
conservative party the Brand's so
trashed if you like in recent uh months
um what are the signs for how he's going
to be as a prime minister well look
they've got a strategy in number 10 and
that is to try and project calm
competence sensible decision making
based on evidence but Sophie let's be
honest we know less about Rishi soon act
than you know any prime minister really
that's come in
oh today there's been quite significant
announcement they've said that they're
ditching all the promises you made over
the summer in that leadership contest
which were probably our best guide to
how we would be as prime minister so
whether it was 10 pounds if you miss
your appointment to see your GP or
income tax cut by the time of the next
election all of that in the bin we only
really have the evidence of him as
Chancellor he's not necessarily the most
calm person in a panic I'd actually say
we know less about how he's going to be
a prime minister than I think many
people even in Westminster realize so
yeah absolutely really interesting to
see what happens to those approval
ratings as we learn more about Rishi
sunak thank you very much Sam always
good to talk well that is it for the
take a very newsy program for you this
week we'll be back next week of course
every week on Wednesday at 9 00 pm and
I'll be back of course Sunday morning 8
30 a.m next off it's news at 10.
[Music]